[Music]
it's a boy Chris Pratt coming back with
an episode of what's my snack it's a
carrot cake muffin Chris goes on a press
tour and the whole world rejoices his
what's my snack Instagram series is back
and he's making the tokyo stock for
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 a family
affair bringing wife on ax paris at four
year old son Jack along come on back up
you [ __ ] through no give me your hand
he captured this photo with honor these
press tours can be such a whirlwind I'm
grateful to have you and the boy with me
on this one and we are grateful he
always makes the tours so entertaining
while promoting passengers he repeatedly
cropped co-star Jennifer Lawrence out of
his photos just crop around pretending
how do you feel about his cropping I
think it's really funny and on his first
guardians tour he revealed a secret
talent by French braiding the hair on an
ET in turn this is not embarrassing it
on haha so we know we're in for a fun
ride as the guardians tour arrives in
Los Angeles next week and then over to
England for a big London premiere
skipper cake mo it could hurt it kemper
cake muffin what's my snack
you
you